joining us now is the Golden Globe
winning actor in succession start needs
no introduction really Brian Cox they're
lovely to have you on the program thank
you very much for for making the time to
be with us
good to be here now I wonder we all know
you've been very busy with succession
recently I don't know if you're working
on anything new but have you had to exit
in a dramatic fashion to join the
strikes today
uh no actually by sheer coincidence it
turns out that I you know the show is
finished so I'm actually going to be
doing a bunch of theater I'm going to be
doing a a playing bath at uh in the fall
in the Autumn I'm going to be doing the
playback actually Johann Sebastian Bach
directed by Trevor Nunn and then in the
New Year I'm going to be in the West End
doing longest journey tonight so I'm
going to be doing theater so and this
was all planned before any of this uh
strike came into play all right so I'm
sure we'll all be booking tickets for
that but do you support uh the strikers
today
absolutely there's no question I mean
you know it's it really is about support
of the uh wga because they came out uh
they're the ones who are not being paid
properly I mean we we also have our
problems that the SAG Screen Actors
Guild does have its problems but it's
also mainly in support of the wga
because without the wga without the
writers we have nothing we depend on the
writers that's why you have shows like
White Lotus like succession and they're
great shows greatly written by great
writers and these writers deserve to be
paid they need to be paid and they need
to be paid well yeah and we're coming in
we have our own we have our own issues
uh one is the AI issue the artificial
intelligence issue and the other issue
is the whole issue of um of uh
residue you know there are repeats
system that we've that has been failing
rapidly and we need to really reorganize
the repeat systems because so much of
our pensions you have to understand that
Screen Actors Guild because we don't
have a National Health in America it we
depend on uh our health we have to pay
health insurance and the health
insurance usually comes from the
residuals that one receives uh that
helps that contributes to it now if our
residuals go down that means our health
insurance is not going to be met so in a
sense we're in a very difficult position
and the AI is is another thing that's
just another sort of let's let's take
those issues just I'm sorry to interrupt
you I know we're going to be up against
time but let's take those issues one at
a time so first of all that issue of pay
it's 26 000 pounds so dollars rather
that you'd need in order in the U.S to
to reach that threshold for health
insurance to qualify for health
insurance in the US a lot of those
people get that as you say the actors
through their residual payments explain
to a British audience what's a residual
payment
a residual payment is every time
something is repeated
um now with streaming shows it's
endlessly being repeated you know we're
still streaming succession still being
streamed and we need to cover you know
we need to cover the expense that that
that we are not getting from that and
that's that's that's the biggest problem
is that uh the residuals go down and
they're paying less and less now in a
way the kind of streaming services have
shot himself in the foot because they
said oh we're doing very well on this
one very well on this front and when we
call them to task and said well look uh
you know what about our residuals what
about our money of course now everything
kind of closes down and says well you
know it's not going to happen and uh
that's that helped precipitate the SAG
Stripes but also the side strike I say
was very much in support of the wga
unlike the Director's Guild who did not
support the wga which I found
astonishing yeah absolutely well let's
so we know it's the first time in 63
years that uh Hollywood writers and
actors are simultaneously striking so
it's obviously supporting each other as
you say both wanting a bigger share a
bigger piece of the pie when it comes to
those profits coming from the streaming
uh Giants you mentioned AI that was your
other your other point and the threat
that that poses to actors I guess there
might be audiences thinking hang on how
does that work in practice How could an
AI replace an actor
well you know AI has you know has sort
of means to a impersonate your voice be
do I mean I've just run into a situation
just now where I was and uh involved in
something and there there was a whole
lot of what EI was suggesting I would AI
was suggesting I would do which was an
absolute nonsense it was a kind of jokey
thing anyway but I found it really
extraordinary that they'd made up this
whole scenario for me which doesn't even
exist it's got nothing to do with who I
am and this is so the illusion and the
reality is suddenly the illusion takes
over from the reality and that's one of
the problems of AI yeah and we see that
of course Harrison Ford appearing so
much younger than he actually is in
Indiana Jones How concerned are you
about the the pace at which we're moving
forward uh with AI I guess sort of
divorced from from the regulation that
maybe needs to surround it
one of the problems is we really don't
know enough about it we don't know we
don't know the extent to which it can
operate but it's it's like it's it's the
boogeyman you know it really is the
Boogeyman there that the AI and
especially when you're going on a strike
especially for your when you striking
certain issues you know the streaming
services could easily go to create AI
artificial intelligence programs which
would be a nonsense it would be and it
would not it wouldn't have there would
never be an original voice so you
wouldn't have an original Jesse
Armstrong you know or the original guy
who's graded the white loaders you
wouldn't have that they just wouldn't
exist and there would be some kind of
Copy Monkey of of of of of of of the
show and that's that is unacceptable
because also at the standard immediately
drops it it it it it it it it it it
works at a level of a lower standard
which is you know I think in our show
we've set a very high standard and it's
a standard that other rights is the
following and uh you know and I I'm all
for the writers I think it's really
about how the writers were treated and
they were treated very badly the actors
of course have always been it's always
been dodgy or not terms anyway yeah we
are now coming out firmly in support and
it's interesting because you are you are
putting the emphasis on on the writers
there of course many of the actors
involved in this uh strike actors who
are far less famous than you far less
well paid than you will be so excited
and grateful to have celebrities you
know big stars like yourself uh joining
that strike the Emmys may have to be
canceled as a result how long do you
think this strike could go on for how
long are you prepared to continue
well I mean I'm in a very fortunate
position because I I had long planned to
do theater uh when I finished doing
succession so I'm I'm already doing a
show I'm doing a playing bath and then
in the New Year I'm doing a play in the
West End so I I'm I was already going
away from television anyway uh but I I
think you know it's it it's a situation
which really could get very very
unpleasant and it could go on for quite
some time I mean you know they'll
they'll they'll they'll take us to the
brink and we will probably have to go to
the bridge so it may not be sold until
really maybe not until towards the end
of the year all right well we look
forward to having you back on there to
talk about it again uh Brian Cox perhaps
even from Bath I'm sure we'll all be buy
tickets thank you very much Brian Cox